(applauding)
- Welcome back to a very
special episode of @Midnight.
It is time to play 22 Fan Fic.
(cheering)
If some published books don't
contact enough grammar errors
and threesomes for your taste.
You might wanna try fan fiction.
Believe it or not, there's
fan fiction of everyone
on this stage right now.
Here to help me with some
very special 22 Jump Street
fan faction, stars
of 22 Jump Street,
Channing Tatum and Jonah Hill.
(applauding)
Shut up. Shut up.
They're just people.
Oh, thanks OK.
OK thank you gentlemen.
Thank you so much
for being here.
You are classing up our
show and making it fancier.
Are you guys ready to
hear some of the smut
that the weirdos of the
internet have written about you?
- Yes.
- Have you ever gone down
any of the fan fiction
rabbit holes before?
You didn't even know that
this was out there, OK.
This will be fun.
First one, this is the game.
You're gonna tell me if
this is fan fiction about
Channing or Jonah.
So is this first fan
fiction about Channing Tatum
or Jonah Hill?
Here we go.
I walked over to his shower
still having my towel wrapped
around me.
When I was getting inside
the shower, to help him,
my towel got caught on a
hook and he saw everything.
The upside to this is that
I got to see his everything.
(whistles)
Now, which one is that?
Which one do you
guys think it is?
- Not it.
(laughing)
- Straight up Jonah Hill.
- OK. You think Jonah Hill?
Let's find out.
The correct answer is.
It's Channing Tatum.
(applauding and laughing)
You even step out of
the shower camera ready.
How the (beep) do you do that?
- You don't know who's
in the shower with me,
getting me ready.
- Oh damn.
(laughing)
- Dude, nice solo.
Nice solo.
- Wait so in this scenario,
you're coming outta the shower
and Riggles in the
corner doing air guitar?
(cheering and applauding)
- Wanna paint the whole picture.
- You know how we do
on 22 jump street.
- Wait, that's how
you do it on 22?
- That's how we do
it on 22 jump street.
- Wait, wait, I don't know about
how we do it on 22 jump street.
I didn't know nothing
about that part.
- Alright next one.
Is this fan fiction about
Rob Riggle or John Oliver?
Or Jonah Hill and
Lee Harvey Oswald.
- That's actually, we're
doing the voices for the new
CG ninja turtles.
That's the cast.
- So here we go.
After his giggling subsided,
he began to get comfortable.
He gazed up at the ceiling,
noticing how much
lighter the room seemed.
Well, with this big
strong marine so close,
what could possibly get him now?
Channing Tatum is blushing.
- Is this about Riggle and
Oliver or Hill and Oswald?
- (Chris) Yes, Riggle.
- It's Oswald dude.
- (Chris) You think
it's Oswald and Hill.
- It's Oswald and Hill.
- Alright let's find out.
Let's find out.
(laughing)
Riggle and Oliver.
- Tickle party convention.
- It's a page turner.
- I just read it.
Sorry that was a
late, late joke.
- Is this fan fiction
about Ice Cube, ice tea
and a model train set?
Or Channing Tatum, Jonah
Hill and a model train set?
The men donned their stripe
conductor hats and blank.
Preceded to show his
guests, each hand painted
and decorated car of
his impressive train.
- Who writes this?
- The internet
just churns it out.
(bell) Ice Cube.
- I think that's
Jonah and Channing.
- (Chris) You think that's Jonah
and Channing, not the ices?
OK let's find out.
- No not the ices.
- I'm sorry.
- You're so close to getting
the (beep) kicked outta you
by Ice Cube.
I don't even wanna
tell you how close.
- Let's find out.
Let's find out.
(cheering)
That is the end of 22 Fan Fic.
I would love to please thank
Channing Tatum and Jonah Hill.
Make sure to check out 22 Jump
Street in theaters June 13th.
Channing Tatum and Jonah Hill.
(applauding)